hey guys in this video I'll show you how
to make custom scenery objects like
benches lights and window boxes with
things that are already available in the
game and how to edit and duplicate them
so let's get started there are two
things you need to know in order to do
this and the first is how to make the
game recognise whatever scenery piece
you're making as a building which will
make sure that all of those scenery
pieces that make it up will be seen as
connected by the game which means that
you can edit it later on or you can
freely rotate it and most importantly
copy/paste it around the park now the
way that I like to get my things within
one building is to just place this very
small roof piece and sink it into
wherever you can't see it which will
make sure that whatever I build after
this will be seen by the game as a
building next I'm gonna want to take the
pieces that I want to make the bench out
of which is this driftwood over here now
the very important thing about placing
whatever scenery object you want to make
your scenery out of is that you have to
place it using the three axis gizmo that
you get by pressing X like this for some
reason only if you do this and will stay
within the same building and if you just
really place it around by using the
cursor or Shift + ctrl it'll just well
be a separate scenery item and not stay
within the same building so you want to
do it like this and you can basically
just move it around with the three x's
if you press X again you can rotate it
like this and pressing X again and we'll
get the three x's again so I'm just
gonna make the bottom of the bench real
quick like this rotate it again to make
the back of the bench just like that yep
to place the object down you can pretty
much just left-click wherever you want
to and then make the back supports of
the bench
sink them into the back a little bit
like that just to provide support for
the top parts rotate that again I always
like to rotate my wooden pieces a little
bit which gives it a bit more realistic
look the word kind of looks like each
piece is a bit different instead of
being the exact same driftwood piece now
finally I want to get a bit of supports
underneath the sitting part of the bench
and move that to the other side as well
and that is the bench pretty much
finished it's a pretty simple bench but
it's about on the scale of a guest and
if you click on it the game sees it as a
building which means that you can just
duplicate it by pressing ctrl D and
basically move it around and place it
around in your park another thing you're
gonna want to know how to do is how to
select the things and duplicate them
within the
same building and how to show this off
I'm gonna make a fence real quick and
I'm gonna do the same just lower this
into the ground to make sure that the
fence will be recognized as a building
then get the planks that I wanna make
the fence out of which would be this
very long drift with blank which is
about the length of a full tile a little
bit less but you can always mask that a
bit and raise it up to make the fence
and just get a couple new ones on the
sides this is probably the worst fence
I've ever made but it doesn't really
matter for the sake of this tutorial so
there we go and this is just one
building much like the bench but now we
want to know how to copy this part of
the building within the same building
and there are two ways to do this the
first one is to hold ctrl down and
left-click on every single piece like
this which means that you can select
them all at the same time and press
control B to duplicate it and you can
duplicate it within the same building
and basically know just make a series of
fences like this and the second option
is to just hold down the left mouse
button and hover over the screen like
this to basically select everything
within that field and that's usually a
little bit quicker if like there is
nothing else around this plot of the
building but imagine that this fence was
built in a pretty busy building with all
sorts of scenery objects right around it
it can sometimes be a little bit easier
and more selective if you just hold down
ctrl and click on the different options
it really depends on if it's the only
thing in the line of sights basically in
most cases if you can get a clear shot
of what you want to copy it's by far
easiest to just drag the cursor over the
screen now as you can see you can use
this quite easily to make a very long
straight fence and even if you have like
three fences like this you can quite
easily just copy all of them over and
place them like that just make sure that
you don't miss out one little drift word
blank there but what I also like to do
is imagine you want to make a curve for
the fence you can just take this one
fence building and just copy that around
and basically make a curve like this
this is obviously a little bit more
time-consuming than straight fences but
it's always a nice way to get a custom
fence in alongside a curvy path so these
are the most important things of this
tutorial and the rest of all pretty much
just be ideas on planters that you can
make or window boxes and things like
that one very interesting and very
to make plants that i like to use is to
just think that since it's grown to make
it one building for some reason this
green arrow sometimes pops up but it
always disappears if you just click the
right mouse button that's all right and
get this piece and what I always like to
do about this is just grab it like that
and just very easily rotate it this way
each one 45 degrees and that way you can
make something which could kind of
function as a little bin or a planter it
really depends on what you want to use
it for but in this case I kind of want
to have it as a little flower planter
pots and you can pretty much do sink any
foliage inside a building as long as you
make sure to use the 3 axis gizmo for it
so as you can see this little flower is
now or this little bush is now part of
the building and you can copy it around
with the building itself next up we have
custom lanterns which are a bit easier
to do because if you use the wooden post
which also spawns aquit itself you don't
have to sink anything into the ground
and you can just place a post and attach
whatever Lantern you want to attach to
it I always like to combine it with this
one and have any sort of additional
decorations that you want to add to it a
little ring on the front for example you
can always use this little stucco I'm
not even gonna try to pronounce that
into the ground to make a little footer
for it or use the drift word which is
quite nice to have any kind of
decoration on the side of it that you
want like some some sort of triangular
things sticking out like that whatever
you can basically come up with there is
a lot of things that you can mess with
when it comes to making objects like
this though in this case I'm just gonna
keep it quite simple just very straight
to the point just at this little corner
stone piece to it to make a footer for
it and that's gonna be my pretty simple
lamp in this case but please do not
think that you can only make scenery
items like this for things that are
standing on the ground you can very well
make things that you actually attach two
buildings that you've already built like
a separate window that's just its own
building that you can basically copy
paste around all of the buildings in
your park or a separate roof whatever
you can think of really of what I
especially like to do is get window
boxes and place those around any kind of
winner any kind of building that needs
some flowers or just
all touch of foliage to make it look a
little bit more alive which is well most
of all the points of things like this
and to make a window box with flowers in
it I like to get these things on the
size of it and stick some driftwood onto
that kind of depends on how large I want
to make these boxes how much driftwood I
want to use in this case I think just
about a length like this should do a
little longer than the smallest
driftwood piece which is a little bit
less than half a tile like this will be
about 2/3 of a tile in width and make
sure that I cover all of what I had
previously over there again rotating
some of the logs just to make sure or
some of the driftwood pieces just to
make sure that they don't all look
identical basically and place this
around the sides here just to make sure
that it's a metal corner and this is
really the base sort of look of this
window box you can always add a bit more
to it if you want to also make sure that
it actually has a bottom because
otherwise it'll look pretty awkward if
you look from the other side so very
quickly also when I add a bit of a
bottom here with basically the same
pieces and actually just use those in
the middle here and that is more or less
everything you need to make a window box
now at this point you can just decorate
it with whatever you really feel like
maybe yeah I want to have like some sort
of cross sort of I have no idea what
that actually is looks pretty cool
though so we're gonna go with that it's
a little bit off-center but that's not
really too big of an issue now you want
to take whatever foliage you want to
have in it and put it inside the window
box I think in this case actually this
one is a little bit nicer more like what
I am going for and in many window boxes
you can kind of see the flowers hanging
over the box itself so don't be afraid
to kind of just make make this kind of
hang out there I just made sure because
these are like very round bushes that
you get the roundness out of them a
little bit by placing a couple in a row
like this and what's also quite nice
with this bush especially this should be
rotated a bit looks a bit unnatural at
the moments what's also quite nice about
this bush in particular is that you can
actually mix it quite well with the
other thing
like this to give it the impression that
it's not just one big very big purple
bush with nothing else attached to it
but actually make it look like there are
some different kinds of bushes in there
or that actually has some green leaves
as well it's the general look that I'm
going for in this case obviously when
we'll get more foliage you can make some
better looking stuff but that's
basically in theory how you can make a
simple window box now to show how you
can use these kinds of items and to
really see how much more alive they make
an area look I've built this little
German set and you basically want to
place these things around wherever you
want or plant them to so I'm gonna have
a few benches I think this would be kind
of like a Main Street kind of idea in
Disneyland imagine the German area in
Epcot or something along the lines of
that's gonna have a few benches around
here maybe clutter the lamps in
alongside the benches as well it's
always quite nice if you cluster them a
bit instead of having them all randomly
over your park and with basically equal
distances between the lamps and the
little bins and the planters and maybe
even put this planter in front of these
things so it doesn't look quite that
good actually think it's a bit better to
place these alongside doors or the
entrances of the buildings that's quite
good
obviously you can't just put any kind of
plants inside of these things which is
quite nice about these flower boxes or
planters and window boxes things like
that you can pretty much keep the box
itself quite the same but have
variations going on of the kind of
foliage that's in it and for the window
boxes it's always a bit of like a puzzle
of where exactly you have to place them
and obviously none of these will be
exactly 100% be aligned with the
buildings but it's not really noticeable
and it's a really nice way to get some
more detail and a bit more of a feeling
of aliveness to any kind of area that
you're making like already it's helping
out quite a lot to just have these
random items spread throughout this part
of the park now what you do see over
here is that you have to be pretty
careful with how you place these things
or how you make them because as you can
see the white things are currently
sticking out so you pretty much have to
keep any kind of great spawning item
within the building at any time is as
soon as I'd well delete this this flower
box is not going to be one
anymore but as you can see it's gonna be
separate items and you definitely don't
want that happening imagine you want to
remove this is gonna take quite a while
or if you want to move it slightly to
the left it's still gonna take a huge
amount of time to replace everything so
usually what I like to do in cases like
this is not remove it actually and edit
its place the new one where you can't
see it which is one over there and
basically do that for every kind of
building where you have to do it
especially with flower boxes I usually
put the hard time in I even did it I
usually put whatever I need to spawn a
grid quite a bit behind the flower box
because you're always gonna you know put
it inside a building and there's a final
touch I'm gonna add the fence at the
side of it and it's pretty much going to
be straight so I can just copy over
those parts and basically duplicate it
one thing that you might see about this
is that every time it's placed a little
bit lower than I actually want to have
it and well it's not that useful of
information but it's something that you
can keep in mind it can save some time
in some cases is that when you when your
selection is only made out of pieces
that don't spawn a grid whatever you're
duplicating is gonna spawn at the bottom
of that building so in this case it's
gonna spawn right at the grid here which
is just below the surface so this is
also gonna spawn just below the surface
from where i duplicated it from now if I
were to put one part of a building which
does spawn a grid like this piece and
then select it it would basically just
come back at the exact same height so if
you want things to keep so if you want
to keep the selection within a building
at the same height you don't want to
lose it all the way at the bottom of
your park map if your building is very
deep or very large you might want to
make sure that you're selecting any kind
of wall or post or roof piece with it
and now that we're having fun with this
kind of thing anyway I could have
probably ended the tutorial over here
but there was still a couple of other
ideas that you might want to give a try
one is to save some time actually you
can lower anything into the ground to
cut things within one building and then
place trees around to be able to
duplicate larger amounts of trees at a
time you have to place the trees with
the 3d kazmo which is a little bit
unfortunate because it's not as easy as
just plopping trees down randomly but um
it's quite handy if you want to make
very large forests at one at a time
because you can just copy over the
plants of the forest and get quite a few
trees in quite a small amount of time in
now just one more idea to kind of get
you going this chimney over here is also
one building it's just a very simple
wooden post in the middle with on the
sides the stucco wall trim piece and in
the middle of it is a stucco pillar
middle section just to make sure that
it's White's on the top and that's
basically a very simple Alpine chimney
though you can obviously have lots of
variations with this as well and that's
the most important point that I want to
get forward in this video is that please
don't just randomly copy all of these
items and put them all over your park
the most important thing here is that
you can make benches and you can make
custom planters and things like that to
get some uniqueness to your parks to get
some items that you don't really see in
other people's parks or to get something
that matches the specific style that you
want to go for for instance you want to
have a very typical sort of fairytale
themed bench but there aren't even any
benches in the game so fine you want to
have a unique kind of object in your
park that's what this is quite useful
for it doesn't take that much time you
only have to make it once and then you
can basically just copy it around your
park so all of this video is just to
kind of give you ideas and tips on how
you can do this kind of stuff but I
really urge you to like make your own
kind of ideas try your own sort of bench
designs and things like this and see
what you can make out of it and
basically hopefully save a lot of time
in the making of your parks and bring
some extra life into your parks anyway
that's all I wanted to say in this video
so thank you guys for watching I hope
you've learned something and have fun
making your own stuff